media changes over time and while
stories and characters have been around
for thousands of years and will be
around for thousands of years more the
medium through which story is
communicated to an audience and how
characters are realized changes
sometimes technology opens up
opportunities in that space and I think
that mobile devices and tablets in
particular because they both offer a
screen but also microphones and speakers
and an Internet connectivity offers a
different method with through which to
create characters and tell stories I
think that when you combine all the
capabilities a modern tablet has the
chance to deliver characters and stories
in a new way it's been presented I think
that Siri gave a hint to that that Apple
released last year and seeing a new way
to both communicate stories to audiences
but also here audiences talk back is
this a thing that hasn't been able to
happen before at any scale other than a
live comedian talking to a audience in a
nightclub to do that actually at scale
today is possible we're trying to create
an experience where your eight-year-old
daughter will be talking to a character
who would listen to her and talk back
and deliver millions of unique
conversations at the same time
can you hear me
could finally hear me I've waited so
long to talk to you to create characters
that are written or in scripted form
like you'd find in the screenplay in a
movie or in a book or a novel any
conversation that occurs in that forum
media is fully encapsulated by the
author when they write the screenplay or
write the book in the case of delivering
a live conversation to an audience we
never know what a child will stay back
to us how they respond to a joke how to
respond to a story we tell or a question
that we ask and so to craft a character
when you're a control of only half the
experience it's a fundamentally
different thing than crafting a
character in a novel or in a screenplay
as the case may be and for us to
discover what that is and what kind of
characters work best in conversation is
us trying to find more about how people
talk to each other how do people connect
that way conversationally we've done it
for thousands of years but but to
actually write that and try to craft it
is challenging but also very rewarding
because when you get it right and we
respond back to a child and tell a joke
that lands at the right time and they
respond back to us as well too and so
begins a dialogue it's completely
magical because suddenly we're in a real
conversation in character in their house
right with them and we're talking to
them what I haven't seen very much of
yet is taking advantage of a greater
combination of the capability to tablets
have just because you have a screen dick
and touch a new ways of controlling
games they'll come out angry birds is of
pull back and catapults which of course
has got huge everybody else that one we
guess I'm a gyroscope you have a
microphone and a speaker and attached to
my sis well too and it will take time I
think for the entrepreneurial community
to investigate the different
combinations of ways to take a use those
things to deliver entertaining
experiences
you